so ich habe hier jetzt montiert sind
beide am laufen und ich hoffe die fliege
ich ab weil die ist echt nicht so
festgefahren wir vorsichtig
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei dem war überlegen ich glaube 6
der alex frisch woche ja letztes mal
liefern nicht so gut
ich weiß nicht ob wir das wieder mit dem
fake iphone gesehen habt das kam ja
letzten sondern ich glaube vorgestern
falls nicht schon durch das gerne an
da haben wir dann ein beispiel dafür wie
es aussieht wenn es nicht so optimal
funktioniert wie sonst aber egal also es
gab ja jeden tag in der alex woche ein
video zum thema wo ich irgendein produkt
ausgepackt habe und heute ist eine fake
doku dran so hier einmal das paket ist
echt stadt angekommen natürlich wie
immer auch unter diesem video ich verlor
sie am ende das produkt und einen 100
euro gutschein wenn ihr daran teilnehmen
wollt an der verlosung schreibt einfach
irgendein kommentar und abonniert mein
youtube-kanal hier oder einigen von euch
ja aus gewinner werden am 25
erster bekannt gegeben und ja also ich
will gar nicht lang lagern wir fangen
direkt mal an ihr könnt euch natürlich
nach dem video dann die ganzen anderen
videos anschauen da könnt ihr nämlich
auch an der verlosung teilnehmen
es wird nämlich in jedem video sehr gut
stand verlost und frei jetzt jetzt hier
los sagte er ich wollte das theater nach
gruppen ob das wirklich das produkt ist
das haben wir heute machen wir das mal
ein bisschen anders und zwar bevor wir
das anfang auszupacken
schauen wir uns erstmal was ich denn da
bestellt habe weil ich bin wirklich sehr
gespannt und ich meine ich habe wirklich
nicht viel für das produkt bezahlt
irgendwie 10 euro sechs euro eins von
beiden so leute das ist das produkt
ultra hd 1080p waterproof also ich bin
mal gespannt ob da so ein case dabei ist
ich kann mich eigentlich mein kopf muss
ganz gut aus aber selber zwei hat mich
12 euro gekostet und wurde auch schon
mega aufgestellt 5570 bestellung theorie
nicht mehr stellung bewertungen das
heißt wir haben bestimmt war ich will
gar nicht wissen nicht wie sich den
schrott schon bestellt haben zumindest
gehe ich erst mal davon aus dass es
schrott ist ich habe mir nämlich mal so
die beschreibung angeschaut irgendwo
stand nämlich was von 15 apps also 15
frames per second so 30 sollten
eigentlich schon drin sein
ich finde es jetzt hier gerade nicht und
wir fangen erst mal an also aufgrund
dieses anzeige bildes hier kann man
direkt auf eine verkäuferin schließen
ich meine die wollen damit natürlich
werben
europa sieht eigentlich eins zu eins
genauso aus sogar hier 1080p full hd
auch noch in verschiedenen farben ich
muss sagen die produktfotos gefallen
wirklich sehr sie
einer hochwertigen kamera eigentlich aus
ja auch gerade wenn man dieses bild hier
sieht ich habe die ganz schlecht glaube
ich in silber und grau bestellt wie halt
auch eine gottlose normalerweise
aussieht wie schaut einfach mal kurz die
bewertung an wir haben 5360 bewertungen
insgesamt 4,1 sterne ist gar nicht mal
schlecht also martin schreibt super teil
für den preis sehr schöne qualität für
den preis super gut das muss ich mal
kurz ein bisschen randori vergessen für
den preis absolut unschlagbar tut was
sie soll empfehlenswert sieht toll aus
würde aber noch nicht getestet trotzdem
immer fünf sterne alles klar
muss mal kurz tür
jetzt hat es geklingelt taugt mir bloß
die grafik ist nicht so gut weil mit 15
apps kann man nicht besonders viel
anfangen oder habe ich das dann gelesen
trotzdem gibt eine gaming fünf sterne
und hier muss ich jetzt noch mal sagen
also ich hab das ding ja noch nicht
getestet aber ich kann menschen in der
heutigen zeit der technik nicht
verstehen die sich so was für 12 euro
kaufen und dann auch noch sagen ja das
ist gut genau so wie es mir vorgestellt
habe also für mich ist das halt wirklich
rausgeschmissenes geld also diese zwölf
euro kann man sich dann auch sparen wenn
man sich so etwas anschaffen möchte dann
muss man dafür schon 50 60 euro ausgeben
das ist halbwegs vernünftig ist
vielleicht irre ich mich auch keine
ahnung haben wir noch ein paar daten so
kamera geht das geht bis 30 meter tief
hält ein bis eineinhalb stunden 1080p
350 gramm und so weiter also genug
gelabert wir machen das jetzt mal auf
und ich bin wirklich gespannt vor allem
dann auf die qualität und was das ding
kann so also schnell ausgemacht
also das ist bis jetzt auf jeden fall
das am meisten verkaufte paket von der
verpackung her also leute schaut euch
das hier mal an so was geht ja nicht
mehr so gut hat ja auch nur 12 euro
gekostet aber irgendwie wollte
anscheinend gar nicht gut mit umgegangen
ja ich hole mal schnell eine meiner
gauchos zum kleinen vergleich das hier
wäre jetzt eine originale gopro hero 4
ist auch schon ein bisschen älter macht
trotzdem gute filme und wir was
eigentlich ganz gut für mich ist ich
weiß jetzt wie kann ich da auch meine
goc vom mit befestigen kann
ja wir haben hier so material um das an
irgendwelchen autos anzubringen keine
handlung wird immer hier zum beispiel
das teil ist ganz wichtig mit diesen
klebestreifen hier auch so gut ladekabel
und der rest ist eigentlich weniger
wichtig so sieht's aus ich finde gar
nicht schlecht vielleicht sogar mit
display hinten drin also wenn man die
beiden jetzt mal miteinander hält hier
das original fake bei man sieht schon
stark ähnlich aus also war nicht zum
verwechseln ähnlich aber schon sehr sehr
ähnlich ich weiß gar nicht wie die
neuesten groß aussehen ob die dann
diesem hier entsprechend keine ahnung
trotzdem erster eindruck an sich nicht
schlecht wir machen das jetzt mal auf ja
und hier haben wir dann auch schon das
gerät mit display das hat mich jetzt
überrascht das hätte ich nicht gedacht
jetzt wird es glaube ich noch mal ein
bisschen mehr deutlich dass es
eigentlich ja fast gleich aussieht ich
habe jetzt den beiden gerade kein akku
drin und diese hier ist deutlich
schwerer
also ob hier überhaupt irgendwann an
technik gryllus weil sie nicht
vermutlich eher nicht so viele leute
dann würde ich sagen ich schließe jetzt
mal einen strohmann lahti beide auf und
dann habe ich mir einen kleinen test
überlegt und zwar würde ich dir gerne an
mein auto montieren und einfach mal so
ein bisschen hier gas geben und dann
haben wir gleich einmal das bild von den
originalen gopro neben dem bild von der
fei pro und das blende ich euch dann mal
ein und dann könnt ihr euch eure eigene
meinung bilden
ja ich bin gespannt was ihr dann am ende
entsteht ich würde sagen wir fangen
einfach mal anlage kann ich lange ich
wünsche euch viel spaß und kommt damit
so leute die kameras werden jetzt gleich
hier angebracht
jetzt ist schon drin aber es ist nur so
eng wenn man es von den nächsten tag ich
habe meine haare gar nicht gemacht
ich fand's zulegen der landstraße wo ich
das testen kann nicht dass sie billig
gopro abfliegt keine ahnung
also auf geht's jetzt zählt ich bin
wirklich gespannt und ich bleibe euch
dann gleich mal so ein vergleich ein
aber ich bin ein tier überzeugung dass
kann ich das gutes werden dass gleich so
ich habe hier jetzt montiert sind beide
am laufen und ich hoffe die fliegt ich
ab weil dies echt nicht so fest wir
fahren wir vorsichtig die ist auch nicht
wirklich jemand da passe ich ein
bisschen auf weil das kann auch wirklich
gefährlich sein wenn man nicht weiß dass
die bombenfest ist ein meiner gruppe
weiß ich's halt bei der anderen jetzt
nicht ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
so leider ist hier irgendwas dran
also das ist irgendwie direkt kaputt
gegangen schade
leute ich bin wieder zurück ich hab mir
grad schon die gopro haufen angeguckt
sehen heute aus wie immer also die
qualität kenne ich ja schon und jetzt
mal eine kleine live action von mir auf
die allen aufnahmen ihr habt sie
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen bin jetzt
wirklich mal gespannt wir haben ja und
nach immer punkt wir haben hier und dann
habe ich so eine uhr eingeblendet das
heißt ja immer wenn er seine uhr läuft
der sound ist ähnlich wie bei der copa
der scheiße
und wir haben da irgendwie die ganze
zeit und so ein fiepen oder ja
ja ich muss sagen so wie es mir
vorgestellt habe also die nimmt
irgendwie automatisch so ein bisschen
heran gezoomt auch wenn man das jetzt
mal mit mit der gopro vergleich aber da
kann ich eigentlich nur sagen also
natürlich haben wir jetzt hier im video
ich meine das müsse jetzt 15 fps sein
das kann man jetzt hier nicht so wie hat
auch ist ein 15 fps mir sind das nicht
also wir haben halt einfach ein stumpfes
bild und man kann erkennen was da
passiert allerdings ist die qualität
natürlich grausam befindest für die
heutige zeit haben die die sagen ich
will jetzt nicht viel geld ausgeben
fallen oder ob möchte ein bisschen unter
wasser was filmen das ist vielleicht
eine notlösung allerdings finde ich das
ist rausgeschmissenes geld also die
zwölf euro kann man dann lieber einen
mittagessen investieren natürlich
verstehe ich es vollkommen wenn jetzt
nicht jedermann sagt er ich hole mir
jetzt für 2 300 euro nur geprobt aber
dann schaut am besten einmal im internet
da gibt es genug auswahl wo sachen 50
oder 60 euro kosten und die liefern
deutlich bessere qualität als das hier
und ich finde das ist es dann auch wert
ansonsten was es mit meinem test es hat
echt spaß gemacht also ich hab es glaube
ich am anfang richtig eingeschätzt so
habe ich mir das vorgestellt und ich
hoffe euch jetzt aufgefallen bin jetzt
sagt sie kommen häufig trotzdem plus 100
euro schein aber hier den kanal und
schreibt ein kommentar und dann nehmt
ihr automatisch zum teil dank fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns morgen wieder
ein neues video
haut rein